okay this is really great stuff a
question I've been asking for weeks now
is if you are opposed to the approved
covid-19 vaccine being required anywhere
why aren't you opposed to a requirement
for the chickenpox vaccine or the polio
or MMR or hepatitis or whatever the case
may be Fox News host Chris Wallace
confronted the Republican Nebraska
governor Pete Ricketts about exactly
that question now Ricketts is again
uh loudly coming out against everything
Joe Biden is trying to do on coronavirus
requirements including most recently the
vaccine mandates and requirements for
employers and others but the very same
Pete Ricketts is fine with tons of other
vaccines this is fascinating stuff let's
watch and listen to the multiple things
that Rickett says because we're going to
break them down one by one in a moment
to attend school in your state of
Nebraska children must be vaccinated
against a number of diseases let me put
them up on the screen they must be
vaccinated against diphtheria tetanus
and pertussis that's the dtp shot that
kids get
polio measles mumps and rubella
Hepatitis B and chickenpox
why are those mandates that parents in
your estate must comply with and do
comply with routinely why is it that
they're not uh so objectionable in such
a violation beautiful personal freedom
but Biden's vaccine mandates are
well for all those that you just listed
there's a long history that parents have
had the opportunity to see how those
things have been implemented so there's
the long history is not actually an
argument it might sound like an argument
but it's not actually an argument he's
not explaining why that should matter
maybe if he tried to explain he could
give us something substantive and we
might be convinced or not but alone
that's not an argument and there's still
a lot of people out there who don't know
what to trust and in fact this is really
an outcome of what the CDC has done
because they flip-flop on so many issues
whether it's mass or whether you have to
mask after being vaccinated and so forth
okay so then he says lots of people
don't know who to trust that's also not
an argument because the question is in
either case with all the vaccines
they're approved by the same body and
then the CDC has flip-flopped this one
I'm very sick of they act like when the
CDC changes their view based on more
data they act like it's just changing
your mind about a movie you like I mean
listen one day you like the movie you're
in a different mood the next day you
don't like it the CDC uses science which
is a process with with a self-correcting
mechanism built in it becomes ideally
more accurate over time and it's not an
argument against one vaccine but not
another remember the question was why is
this vaccine requirement not okay and
that one is so it's in particular not
not an argument against that there's
just a lot of people out there who don't
know who to trust right now and so by
having the government force it on you're
not building a trust where we have the
trust with those other vaccines now
remember it's also not being forced your
employer can choose to let people test
out each week instead of being
vaccinated or not if your employer
doesn't want to as Republicans like Pete
Ricketts want employers to be able to do
this is a process it's going to take
time to bring people along and that's
why it should be a personal choice and
not something mandated by the government
but but forgive me sir I'm old enough
that I remember when the polio vaccine
first came out a lot of us and certainly
our parents viewed it as a blessing and
immediately I lived in New York state at
that time the state mandated that we all
get the polio vaccine right so you know
we're in the middle of a pandemic there
is a new vaccine that Donald Trump was
largely responsible for it's been
approved full approval by the FDA again
if if the polio vaccine is okay for for
parents and they have to comply with it
to send their kid to school why not
Chris Wallace is doing a good job here
for a lot of people not just kids the
vaccine for uh for this disease
yeah and I think this is very different
from polio that has very devastating
effects and certainly we know if you're
older you know 65 years and older that's
where 83 of our deaths in Nebraska so
then he drops in well polio is
devastating well then talk about another
condition I mean the the death rate of
chickenpox is really low it's one per
100
000. if you look at slightly older kids
it's six per 100 000. it's very
contagious but it's not very deadly so
the point here is he has no good answer
and this is a question we've been asking
for a while look at all these other
requirements for vaccination they're
only talking of most 99.9 percent of
them are only talking about the covet
vaccine requirement they are pathetic
they don't have an answer that they're
able to articulate if they can come up
with an actual substantive explanation
I would gladly review it and think about
it and maybe they will convince me one
of our sponsors is curiositystream the
only subscription streaming service just
for documentaries my girlfriend and I
have been using the Curiosity stream
platform at home non-stop I can tell you
from personal experience much better
documentary selection than Netflix Hulu
or Amazon on curiositystream I'm always
finding documentaries by the world's
best filmmakers stuff you can't find on
other streaming services last month they
added a ton of awesome new titles to the
library I just finished watching
becoming Martian about the future of the
human species and its possible path
through Mars but there's documentaries
on every topic imaginable science nature
history politics if you love
documentaries the way I do you are not
going to find a better source of brand
new award-winning docs anywhere else
curiosity stream is giving my audience
25 off that means you can subscribe for
just 15 bucks a year very reasonable
considering the n endless number of
Super quality documentary content that
you have access to just go to
curiositystream.com Pacman the link is
right underneath this video